I read on the book I think it was a
Paulson wrote back in my chest in 15
2016 and he was talking all about China
and kind of his experience there but one
of the things that really stuck out to
me was the whole idea like that entire
political system and social structure is
built on there being a lack of social
unrest right that the second that people
see unrest like this thing could flip
very quickly and so a lot of what they
do is you know quote-unquote taking care
of the people I guess how much of the
narrative around their driving
manufacturing their driving you know
technological advancement artificial
intelligence kind of leaps and stuff
coming out of China how much of that can
save them or maybe prolong what you're
talking about versus like that the
trends are just too powerful and it
won't really actually matter the trend
that matters is their social control
program they've basically blocked off
the Chinese internet from the rest of
the world and they're using it in other
data management tools some proto AI
stuff in order to manage their
population so that whenever you do have
to be perfectly blunt three people
getting together in the same room to
talk about the government the government
knows and can use its army of sensors
and thugs to basically break it up it's
never been tried before it's very
Orwellian we're now actually having a
situation where the Chinese government
is installing monitors in people's
apartments if they're suspected of maybe
having kovat in order to have enforced
quarantine so you know things that in
this country are in the realm of fiction
are are now being implemented on a
regular basis ethnic cleansing is being
done this way forced sterilizations what
they're doing with the Weezer's out in
Jiujiang you know million people in
concentration camps they're trying to
take the best data management tools
available and use it to force the unity
of the Han identity as defined by the
CCP you know
can you imagine what Milosevic would
have done with these technologies and
now we're seeing it done on a scale
that's like what two orders of magnitude
larger
that's the only way that this works and
even for that to work the United States
still has to keep providing global
security and asking for nothing in
return because the only way they can
keep that going is if they can continue
to access resources and export markets
so the the most likely future here were
China holds is the u.s. stops doing what
it's doing the lights go out in China
because the power goes out because they
can't import their materials anymore the
export markets disappear and we drop
into kind of a neo Maoist tyranny where
the standard of living in China just
absolutely plummets and they just kind
of become completely inward focused in
the few chapters of Chinese history
where the center has held its kind of
looked like that they'll just be doing
it with you know webcams as opposed to
monitors on every corner it's not a
pretty fit picture and almost all the
other scenarios are worse so I totally
understand why they're willing to
denigrate their own population to that
degree to mean to remain in control
because the alternative is implosion in
chaos and you know that's the hardly a
friendly version at all that but Chinese
are fairly a student students of their
own history they understand what's at
stake here
yeah before we move on to another part
of the world what would have to change
or what data would you have to see to
kind of change your mind as to like this
is where we're headed if I saw X my mind
would actually turn happen we would have
to have a significant change in
technology that allows people over age
65 to commute to to continue to work and
pay taxes coupled with a social change
that forces them to continue to work and
pay taxes most of our medical
breakthroughs when it comes to people
aged 55 and over is about extending life
not extending working life and that
mindset has to changed radically for us
to go in a different direction and I
guess part of that is a technological
change is the type of work could also
change right so just because you're
getting older
you may not be able to go into the field
or go into the factory and kind of do
more of the manual labor but if there
was even something that could change the
way that people work itself that also is
part of that you know that would be one
way but I think we all know that
convincing our parents to use Skype has
been a bit of a challenge these last
couple of weeks and trying to train
people who thought they were going to
retire in an entirely new industry and
that's that's a reach